hello and welcome to this video playing
i am prince panic villa hendrix okay i
have no draw against oh that's cool
eight wins for losses i am not moving
it's a bad idea while looking at this
statistic I was completely forgetting to
move so um we had a king's indian last
time I remember this and you know he
tries for a sun mon offbeat king's
indian style line let's see let's see
what we get oh that's surprising this
position has a reputation of being
really good for white okay we'll see
what is ideas white gets that and it's
believed to be pretty good like Bishop
e3 and my 22 ok i'm playing this
aggressively with g4 it's not necessary
you can also play in a somewhat more
restrained way and just with cancelling
but i always liked those lines where you
can try to expand on the King side and
ask black or discount the players sort
of other sound in the background is i
think i have to update my my virus
patterns or something like that and i
keep forgetting to do that yeah the idea
g4 is to make it f5 more difficult it's
taking a long time you i would also just
play g5g five h4 h5 don't ya so here
interesting i can go h 4f 5 h 5
let's go ahead
on f4 I can take even though this is not
completely as it's not the most
convincing version of this of this idea
hmm should I have thought about this a
bit longer maybe maybe I should have
done that because here i don't have g5 I
don't have g5 which I would like to play
him oh and it was a bit to be too hasty
now it was a bit too hasty i would like
it to get in g5 and Bishop g-form it was
to a bit too quickly played at age four
h5 thing
now it is probably ok here now let's see
what how to do that you know how to play
this position I would still like to get
in g5 and Bishop chief form maybe I can
prepare it like that the g5 porn is weak
though not sure it's such a good idea to
play the move in the first place then
it's probably isn't a good idea at all
let's not do that Bishop a form is
another way of trying to trade that
Bishop maybe I can get this in I have
not yet played the move f3 because I
felt that I don't want to give up on the
idea to put the knight on f3 ok I have
to cover g4 for the moment and Bishop a4
is still possible if I do that he might
place his six however this is something
that I just spotted no I still want to
try
c6 is not clearly beneficial foam okay
that looks nice that looks nice for
white but how do i how to continue I can
trade those but i think i can activate
the King first the king should be safe
on the three yvette covers a foreign
term and see for myself a better endgame
insider with this bad bishop that i can
play against maybe and put surprise that
here is so relaxed and Jack going into
this year
it's a pretty miserable end game if you
trades
yeah the king is here now to make em
neither three possible even though I
have to say if i go to f3 I'm not sure
if I do do much on that square
interesting okay i want you i want to
kick the bishop back with nida three and
then see what happens I don't want to
play a three years while I'm trying the
same o seagoing g5 if I play that move I
will be interesting no yeah
or looks nice but how to win or to win
this position or let's say first how to
get somewhere is the thing maybe this I
don't know can I go by hmm I could try
to go to see six tonight eight seven and
so on okay allows me to trade no hmm
okay
maybe this is all too closed maybe it is
but how'd you do that
how to do that
I need to enter of course interesting
for Queen age seven okay that I cannot
allow because they're okay maybe maybe
bring the night around a night via to be
5 and so on Oh check this is something
that I have to do if he allows me okay
so what I'm Kate now and then can I do
this and then invade with the invade
with the King takes takes is that
counter fly yes that counter-plan the
kingside 92 King each six can he gets
there he gets them okay Oh didn't see
them glad I had no no I'm so I can still
try him there is no need to take a draw
ok we need be 16
black forfeits our time yeah it was a
pretty one-sided position but it wasn't
clear i can win and to us um I don't
think I played that they're part of the
game very well I mean here might can
already play with short castles easily
because that kind of setup is pretty
good this this kind of setup is usually
the ideal setup with white getting in
before later and winning time on that
night black can never fully block the
queenside that's not possible um so when
maybe this is a bit a bit too much but
yeah here maybe here you can you can can
try to improve here I don't think this
is so great and then with hindsight I
mean here this position is not bad for
white but I don't get this traded easily
which is my goal and would be good if I
had stuck g5 Bishop g4 but I don't I
don't get it in and I cannot just
sacrifice a pawn I mean he will take it
and I cannot play Bishop g4 so I played
in the in the in a slow fashion just
keeping everything let's say and see
what happens and and now I got dead end
I was thinking you would probably play
c6 and to make things a little bit more
difficult for me but Jeff didn't do it
but Justin you just took which makes it
yeah the position remains very one sided
with this bad bishop but it's really
questionable if I can win I mean I have
my doubts gentlemen know this was this
happened oh now I have a very strong
continuation that I didn't see how
computer g5 is very strong Bishop takes
a night to see cell ha and that's very
strong and I didn't see that
didn't look for a tactic in the first
place very strong yeah after the Queen
takes I'll take care and this is
terrible now I'm threatening this and
this and why does probably winning him I
was very nice no I didn't see that
coming okay and in this position I have
my doubts that I can win I think he
would should probably draw but well of
course I can always try I mean I the
only one with some chances yet here he
has this idea this counterplay idea and
this is why I cannot just to just go
with the king like this this year now
and I love losing so I have to have to
be alert it's also why i went here first
there to make sure that nothing happens
on them on the Kings side and now I had
to play this okay I run over there yeah
this is losing but he had no time so
this this yeah this is what he has to do
and this might be a draw
can play this yeah that's at all let's
draw I cannot cannot do much here i can
i can play three before but this is
really not not leading to anything yeah
something like that i don't i don't make
any any headway here can you even take
him now that's a drawer it's always like
it looks better for white because of
that pretty awful looking bishop but
it's really just the draw okay thanks
for watching